[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as 14 ans
tu prévois déjà ça
j'ai pas tu peux pas te lancer dans des
projets genre tu as 14 ans tu parles
déjà d'avoir des gosses je sais pas
à 14 ans
même si même si tu es mature genre tu
vois
je sais pas à 14 ans
[Musique]
là
une maison genre tout de suite
[Musique]
mais ça on n'en sait rien ça c'est le
destin aussi le destin
Imagine Ton ton gars il habite à
Marseille
non mais non mais c'est une question
enfin imagine tu pars en vacances tu
rencontres tu t'en vas amoureuse tu vois
jusqu'à là c'est bon sortirai pas avec
mais oui mais après tu peux tomber
amoureuse etc et puis
[Musique]
du coup imagine
bah non on va déjà je choisirais pas un
gars de Marseille ou de plus loin vous
mais dans tous les cas je vais déménager
[Musique]
30 minutes peut-être mais c'est chiant
mais dans tous les cas c'est la même
chose la semaine prochaine tu es plus
avec on imagine c'est tout c'est pas
vrai tu imagines juste je sais pas
c'est dans ton instinct c'est dans ta
tête c'est toi qui est vraiment tu le
sais tu le deviens c'est pas tu choisis
c'est tu deviens
comment tu le sais genre comment ça fait
pas dans ta tête
non c'est juste que c'est bien imagine
genre après bah ça se réalisera pas
il aura pas de boulot ou un truc comme
ça ça t'en sais rien au contraire il va
réussir dans sa vie là il va continuer
ses études enfin il va il va travailler
moi même je travaillais ça va être un
bon père imagine il trouve pas de boulot
ou un truc comme ça pas dans tous les
cas il va trouver quand même quelque
chose il va pas rester au chômage
à rester au chômage quand même j'avais
vu travailler veut avoir une vie
heureusement tu peux pas le dire c'est
un bâtard tu l'as vu qu'une seule fois
puis après tu dis que c'est un bâtard en
fait mais oui mais c'est la première
impression et puis je l'aime pas genre
je suis arrivé je dis ah lui j'ai un peu
je peux pas dire ça tu juges alors que
tu connais même pas enfin ça se fait pas
envers la personne imagine toi on te
voit d'un seul compte juste ça va pas te
plaire bah lui je pense que ça va pas le
faire non plus
mettons j'ai un gars et genre genre tu
l'aimes pas bah tu vas pas dire ah je
l'aime bien je l'aime bien non tu dis
pas il faut que je la prenne à le
connaître mais ouais mais tu dois dire
ce que tu penses quand même mais non il
faut que tu apprennes à le connaître tu
vois tu juges trop vite tu sais que
quand tu vas avoir un copain ou une
copine ça va être pareil
je suis là quand même oui mais non mais
moi j'ai l'impression genre j'ai
l'impression je suis plus là
d'être avec ton copain oui mais tes
potes ils existent quand même mais oui
mais après on oublie quand même un peu
d'un côté j'ai essayé bien aussi les
amis mais d'un côté tu as besoin d'être
avec ton copain sinon ça va pas aller
dans ta relation moi je continue à dire
que à 15 ans tu as pas la meurtrier pour
avoir des enfants les regards
peut-être pas son copain il travaille
peut-être pas mais au final regarde ces
enfants ils sont super bien ils sont
enfin ils sont pas ils sont pas non plus
dans les rues enfin elle a de l'autorité
etc c'est une bonne mère ben moi je
trouve qu'elle s'occupe pas vraiment de
ses enfants et que genre ils sont quand
même assez jeune et qui sont dehors ils
sont pas tout le temps dehors
j'avais pas dehors
sa petite hein
elle s'en sort dans la vie elle a pas la
vie je foutue enfin franchement elle est
bien
elle est heureuse
[Applaudissements]
et qu'il y en a
tu fais la gueule
mais qu'est-ce un peu de fer en fait
de faire ta gueule vas-y la réponse
vas-y dégage j'ai pas envie de te parler
bonjour
[Musique]
ça va pas trop en ce moment je me sens
triste je sais pas où j'en suis je suis
perdu
la dernière fois je suis rentrée j'ai
été dans ma chambre mais je me suis mise
à pleurer je savais même pas pourquoi
je crois que j'ai l'impression de pas
être libre
genre enfermé comme si ma vie elle était
déjà tracée en fait
je l'ai l'impression que je suis pas une
gamine mais je suis pas une adulte non
plus
quand j'étais petit je me posais pas
toutes ces questions c'était plus simple
maintenant il y en a qui sont en couple
ils ont leur vie de famille elles ont
des enfants
comment je m'occupe s'il y en a pas il y
en a pas
ça s'est fait comme cela
j'avais
12-13 ans
en gros j'étais méchante entre
guillemets
j'avais de la haine contre les gens je
sais même pas pourquoi même les gens qui
m'avaient rien fait et tout je mets de
la haine contre
j'étais plus en train de traîner avec
des garçons que avec des filles si je
passais dans la rue qui avait quelqu'un
qui me regardait mal ou quoi je disais
ouais c'est quoi ton problème
tu me fais pas peur
je traite et tout le monde même les
profs je les insulter
[Musique]
vous faites quoi
que c'est vous
c'est dégagé
[Musique]
OK
mais pourquoi vous êtes venus déjà
cassez-vous non
je crois de me faire peur en plus
fouille
ta gueule pouillé dégage
toi ta gueule
quand je suis arrivé au lycée je me suis
dit faut que je me comporte bien quoi
j'ai grandi faut que je devienne mature
alors qu'avant je me prenais pour un mec
j'étais toujours en survêt et tout je
m'étais d'été
j'étais un garçon manqué quoi
quand j'ai vu que toutes les filles bah
ils s'habillaient bien enfin
ils étaient je sais pas comment
expliquer mais féminine et il y avait
que moi qui est en survêt quoi je me
suis dit bah je vais essayer de
redevenir comme ça quoi
et après bah j'ai réussi à me rhabiller
comme une fille j'ai commencé à remettre
mes jeans
mes croctes
on pourrait accepter et pour que les
gens ils arrêtent de parler et qu'ils
arrêtent de m'insulter
voilà séduire qu'on va draguer
quelques mots
[Musique]
déjà il faut faire beau gosse
ça c'est important
la laine surtout
que si tu pues de la gueule
ça va aller pour aller mieux
sinon tu fais tu fais que de la regarder
tu fais des chaises genre il y a un mot
de tu viens tu fais genre câlin sur la
joue ou l'offre exemple ou je sais pas
quel parc
et puis tu fais les cheveux surtout et
ça elle te dit arrête j'aime pas tu
arrêtes et voilà
c'est pas un peu loin là
c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire pour
draguer
je sais pas des trucs d'amour
tu me manques trop
tu me manques
en couple d'accord
[Musique]
tu me
manques
tout on va en fait forer nous je suis
pas moi
je sais pas
un truc là
on va éviter l'hôtel
je sais pas dans ta chambre j'ai pas
chez toi chez ta mère chez
ton oncle je sais pas moi
c'est un truc c'est toujours coucou ça
va tu fais quoi
tu veux pas coucher
normal
[Musique]
je sais pas moi
c'est pas ça du tout
je te fais des bisous de temps en temps
[Musique]
la personne voilà quoi c'est ça
du son alors c'est quoi vas-y
intelligente
[Musique]
c'est quand tu arrêtes pas de la
regarder tu la regardes dans les yeux et
lui ou elle pareil
mais si ce qu'on te dit en plus
il te regarde tu le regardes il te
regarde
tu t'approches et tu t'approches tu
t'approches et s'approche
la fille de mes rêves
bon moi je la vois blonde
les cheveux longs
[Musique]
poitrine loyer
on s'en fout des formes
un peu bleu
non les femmes
tu peux pas comprendre en fait
tu peux pas comprendre ce que nous les
garçons ressent tout ça
vous les comprenez pas ça
qui mettait directement le truc des
garçons directement dans la ville des
filles
[Musique]
le vélo
de faire le bébé en fait de faire la
forme du bébé
c'est pour le plaisir et l'amour c'est
pour faire des gosses
[Musique]
pour moi c'est
cool et en vrai c'est pas le plaisir
quoi c'est il y a pas trop vraiment
différent
ouais il y a pas trop de différence en
vrai il y avait même je crois pas du
tout
parce que c'est un peu les mêmes choses
et l'amour c'est pour faire des trucs
sérieux
un peu baiser tu mets la capote et faire
l'amour tu mets pas de la capote
après
il y a pas trop de différence vraiment
[Musique]
[Rires]
un grand malade
c'est quoi le problème
c'est pareil j'ai bien fait de te
séparer
mais après il parle du quoi
non mais moi
j'aurais poussé mais genre toi tu me
risques pareil moi lui il pousse tu le
pousses je te sers normalement
là je voulais pas avoir
[Musique]
on est tous potes pourquoi tu fais pas
travailler avec eux
avant
depuis qu'ils ont cherché
et lui il venait de chercher des fois
lui porter tu veux chercher mais non il
a arrêté il faut que tu arrêtes
pas même plus de Big Show il va me
rendre fou
qu'est-ce qu'on pourra parler
on continue
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as déjà galoche bah oui et
toi
et toi
[Musique]
ça sert à rien on a tous les deux un
petit nez
quoi mais pour moi c'est les meufs en
fait qui font
qui font leur intéressante
[Musique]
non mais
avant blague
[Musique]
ils ont ils ont toujours mettre plein de
maquillage
mascara du rouge à lèvres rouge bleu
jaune
avec des talents qui font ça
des faux-ongles après d'autres c'est pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
de l'humour
tu fais tu fais des caprices à maman
pour avoir des faux-ongles
comme elle elle
est toujours vulgaire
ça définit pas le mode de [__]
[Musique]
vive les mariés
je suis en switch aussi
[Musique]
il y en a pas souvent des couleurs comme
ça
c'est pas bon
tu t'es fait un parking
[Musique]
si j'en ai à la langue
c'est une
tu me donnes la main
regarde mince regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fais-le fais la moto
il veut te faire un câlin
[Musique]
er ta maman
c'est pas trop compliqué en ce moment
avec la petite
tu fais quoi
tu as trouvé ton appart non pas encore
il me positionner sur un début novembre
sur l'avenue au-dessus de la pizzeria
mais tu veux rester dans le quartier
tu veux d'autres enfants bah pas pour le
moment je vais attendre déjà qu'il
n'ayant elle puisse comprendre qu'elle
va à l'école
qu'elle va à l'école que
[Musique]
elle grandit un peu pour après lui faire
comprendre par la suite
les douleurs mais après une fois qu'elle
arrive tu oublies tout en fait
maintenant il faut penser à elle
faut faire avec
mais tu sortais plus je voulais beaucoup
me reposer aussi
avant son arrivée
je me manquais quand même bonjour c'est
très bien
les
oiseaux
[Musique]
et toi ça va depuis le temps bah ouais
bof genre je suis un peu perdu et tout
ah bon pourquoi faire
je sais pas
[Musique]
après quand tu as pas la tête à parler
que tu veux être seul
[Musique]
non
c'est pas à manger maman
je suis un peu malade
je commence à grandir parce que le début
je suis genre je vais être un homme quoi
dans ma tête je suis encore un genre
je sais pas comment dire ça genre dans
ma tête je suis encore arrivé à 3 ans
plus on est grand plus que il y aura des
bourbiers dans sa vie qui vont arriver
je sais pas mais bon bah à quoi ça sert
de se battre
moi je suis pas un emmerdeur mais en
fait moi j'attends que c'est eux qui
viennent manger
je me faisais victime par tout le monde
j'étais la [__] ou la plus de tout le
monde en fait je me faisais frappe par
tout le monde
tu vois tu connaissais des bonnes
personnes genre je comptais sur eux mais
toi tu me dis frappé bah non
juste parce qu'en fait c'était le plus
fort du collège
et puis il y a pas il y a pas si
longtemps il y a deux mois
en fait j'ai compris en fait que
maintenant j'ai grandi et maintenant je
me défends en fait
plus depuis ce jour-là
en ce moment c'est des trucs viré de mon
collège en fait
je travaille bien j'ai des bonnes notes
mais c'est mon comportement qui plaît
pas
j'ai pas envie de dormir en internat et
j'ai pas envie de boire mon petit frère
que trois jours par semaine quoi
genre juste je le ferai pas c'est
toujours avant moi toujours
moi j'ai 7 ans plus que lui donc
maintenant c'est à moi de montrer
l'exemple donc je sois ado c'est encore
un petit temps un petit gosse genre
[Musique]
son grand frère donc
on sait pas ce que c'est que de
ressentir les autres qu'en fait quand on
est petit quand on est grand en fait on
peut savoir ce qu'ils ont les autres ce
qui me ressentent les autres quand
lecture c'est quoi ça
j'en sais pas ce qu'on veut en fait
qu'on est grand c'est ce qu'on veut
faut plus avoir besoin de ses parents
pour faire des petites choses pour faire
ceci cela il faut il faut se débrouiller
tout seul
quand tu es grand tu as tout ce que tu
veux quoi
genre des enfants une belle maison
ça me
va avoir dans merde etc
je pense que c'est ça le bonheur en fait
[Musique]
toi
il est encore chaud
[Applaudissements]
il y a un nœud
c'est pas grave
non il y a un gros
et on va refaire
[Applaudissements]
il était gros petit
[Musique]
vous êtes la bienvenue on va éclater une
pierre je sais pas monter [__] de sa
grand-mère
voilà ma sœur [__] de sa grand-mère la
[__]
il y en a
il y a une capote
toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
non non
une grosse
[__] j'avais pas trouvé
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie
après
dans 5 minutes
après c'est bon
bateau estivale
[Musique]
l'autre jour je me suis levé au matin
j'ai pris mes affaires
je suis parti rejoindre des copines
ensuite on a marché jusqu'à la mer
on a marché pendant des heures
on a lancé les côtes
on est arrivé sur une plage on a mangé
je me suis allongé dans le sable j'ai
fermé les yeux
et je me sentais bien j'étais loin de
tout loin du quartier loin du lycée loin
de ma famille
[Musique]
genre j'avais envie de de plus repartir
j'avais envie de disparaître
je crois que j'étais bien là-bas je
voulais rester
[Musique]